you know what's amazed me about
streaming no matter what obscure thing i
do just one goddamn expert appears out
of nowhere in the chat one goddamn like
you know i'll be doing like sudoku and
the world 2017 world sudoku champion
will come in my chat and be like hey
what are you doing this technical fringe
you know what i mean like no matter what
i do somehow an expert comes out of
nowhere yeah what is this like [ __ ]
reddit yeah yeah
it's insane i'll be like do like a water
grading stream and like the guy who
designed water will appear in my chat hi
i discovered water
like um there'll be like a movie or a
song that i know for a fact only like 10
000 people have heard or listened to and
someone in chat knows about it oh i
remember that wait do you and they do
yeah i'm the producer
i mean of course
that very obscure childhood memory that
you have of a game or a show and then
you describe it and then chat is like oh
i know what that is of course i know
what that is i'm like wild how do you
how do you know
what's wrong with you guys
i just know i mean chat is a curse but
also like an almighty being that just
knows everything it's pretty impressive
it is oh it's like a conglomerate yeah
it's it's weird like see seeing seeing
people refer to chat it's like yes it's
i don't know such a weird concept to me
because you know everyone in chat is an
individual person but then chat just
becomes just melds into this one
entity
yeah one all-knowing entity that is uh
equally single brain cells
it's like being part of hollow live um
of course you are
you stream on youtube but what do you
think about the whole twitch streaming
as well have you ever been interested in
streaming on twitch and what kind of
differences do you think that would make
if you ever did
it's pretty unexplored territory to be
honest so i haven't really thought too
much about it um i feel like you know i
have watched a couple streamers on
twitch but for whatever reason i just
feel like i gravitate more towards
youtube i know that they both have their
pros and cons for sure but i've gotten
so comfortable on youtube and one thing
that i really love about it
on youtube especially is that uh
archives are kept forever
you know so my streams become videos
that people can just watch whenever they
want and that's true check out the whole
backlog you know i really love that but
um i do think that for example twitch's
sub feature is superior that is certain
but um i think they both have you know
their pros and cons i just feel like at
this point it's like a comfort thing i'm
just so used to youtube now and and the
way that people you know interact with
each other in chat there there are so
many layers to it that i just kind of
prefer yeah i find it really curious or
really weird to see like both these
platforms just having different cultures
around them and it's almost like a
different etiquette where like when
you're on a twitch twitch stream just it
it feels completely different to
watching a youtube stream yeah and i'm
not sure like i'm not sure if it's just
the community or if it's just like
emotes or what it is but yeah both both
platforms to me feel oddly
different whenever i'm watching a
different creator stream on that
platform
there's like a culture to it for sure i
have noticed because i i watch uh
streamers who stream on both and it is
quite different i gotta say
that's not me that's not me being like
that's not i'm not throwing any shade at
twitch i'm just i'm just saying that
i mean it's it's not paying you it's not
for me um but i mean at the same time
it's just what you prefer at the end of
the day everyone's got their preference
and uh just choose what you like and
that's how it goes like yeah like i i
don't think i'd have a difficult time
streaming on youtube now that i'm just
so used to streaming on twitch yeah the
vibe is different as well yeah
definitely is totally different people
are
way more joking on twitch i think people
are used to people are monkeys on twitch
we got a couple monkeys on youtube oh
that's true but but it is a kind of
different feeling for sure um at the end
of the day though i will go to where the
creator i like is that is the truth for
me personally but that's not always the
case for everyone you know everyone's
kind of different yeah some people are
lazy to like open another tab i don't
get it i get it i mean
guys god is that guy clicking clicking a
link to go on another platform get out
of here
get up no i mean like my poor thingy
can't handle it no because like i mean i
mean there's just so many platforms
nowadays and so many different apps and
stuff that sometimes you just talk to my
mum yeah i mean something absolutely i
can't handle all the jobs
sometimes you just build up a uh like
schedule the right word no it's a
pattern you build up a pattern about
what time you spend on each app right so
like i've been watching a lot of youtube
shorts nowadays even though i could go
and t and even though they're just
recycled tick tocks right but it's just
it's just because i'm as a youtuber i'm
just on youtube more that it's just more
convenient for me and so i don't like if
you watch a lot of twitch streamers then
sure it's easy to watch more twitch
streamers but if you're not like
integrated into that kind of ecosystem
it's like it's it's weird it's because
like it feels like you're going more out
of your way just to view this one
creator as opposed to just being on the
platform naturally you know so i i do
think it is a factor that matters which
is why you see
a lot of people who are just famous on
one platform nowadays you can have
people who are famous on youtube and
just not have a presence anywhere else
and you you know and i feel like i feel
like the super super successful content
creators are people who can like break
out of that just one platform and be
able to like have a presence on multiple
platforms right i mean i am a person who
kind of feels like consistency is a big
key but some people are so big that it
doesn't matter you know it doesn't
matter where you go people will follow
kind of thing you know um but i do i do
kind of see like the uh the merit and
having all your stuff in one place it's
also just personally what i prefer
because of how my brain works you know i
like to have everything in one place
because i'm already a really big scatter
brain in the first place if i had stuff
all over the place i'd lose my mind so i
kind of you're juggling enough things as
it is honestly
there's a lot going on
so i'm just scared to have everything on
one platform right like yeah you know
i'm that mentality of like just put
don't put all your eggs in one basket
kind of thing i do think that however
music is like the one thing that is like
yeah easily able to hold it tired oh
yeah yeah like it's like i mean that's
why every youtuber on earth tries to
become a pop star or yeah yeah because
varying levels because because that's
where you know money is good uh
longevity is good you can you can have
time to work on it music is definitely
also it doesn't matter how old you get
right you can still keep yeah you can as
long as it sounds good
on youtube you know you turned 30 oh
bye-bye sorry guys you're uh
what
that's right
why was his reaction so i mean 30 years
old man
yeah i'm having i'm having trouble
hearing already
it's not really just trying to age gate
we are joking we are friends we're
allowed to make these jokes all right
it's like you have to clarify that
you're bantering these days let's calm
down a little bit you know
is it the same is the same on uh
hollow live with the with the friends
these people get upset when you mock
each other you know i will say um we
like to we like to banter quite a bit um
but we gotta remind y'all again and we
really don't have to but i'm going to
anyway we are all really good friends
yeah exactly
and so
at the same time you know a lot of us
have kind of i mean i know i certainly
came up in friend groups where we would
we would you know
throw [ __ ] at each other and it was all
in good fun we never really kind of step
over the line it's it's all stuff that
we're comfortable with and it's just
it's just good fun no no one hates
anyone just you know sometimes you gotta
calm down take a step back um we know
each other pretty well and um it's just
like that sometimes we're having fun
there's really just like some people
though that just don't get that whole
like bantering or like you know when is
it over the line or like you know there
are people like over analyze
conversations on streams and youtube
videos where it's like this is the frame
this is the very frame where their
friendships started to crumble ever have
you seen them streaming since then i
don't think so not friends anymore it's
like no dude it's like it's fine yeah i
feel like like even more so with like
the v tubing community because um
do you ever feel like a lot of people
like really really analyze
what you like what your behaviors are
yeah like maybe a bit too much sometimes
yeah i'd say so i've seen several
paragraphs analyzing my personality from
my deepest insecurities to things that
uh everyone already knows etc i've seen
plenty of things like that um
and you know it's just it's gonna happen
it's gonna happen when so much of
yourself is put out there you know
that's just how it's gonna be but uh i
will say
um it is the truth we really do only
give a percentage of ourselves uh when
we stream even though it may be so many
hours in a day um there's still a whole
side where we go off and live lives i'm
still you know occasionally reaping the
occasional soul don't tell that sensei
about that but you know i'm i'm doing
other stuff as well and it's important
to remember that it's important to like
take a deep breath and realize that you
know we've all got lives so where does
music fit into your career like
how do you find time for that where did
you find time for that uh i mean i think
that the only only thing i can say is
it's just it's the one thing that i love
doing so completely and utterly that
time just isn't a factor to me energy
isn't a factor to me all of that just
disappears in me wanting to create music
and i don't compromise anything for it i
believe that's called a passion
that's pretty
sounds like a passion
to me so no matter what i will find a
way to fit it in even if other things
have to kind of you know take a back
seat um even things like streaming etc
which will not make everyone happy but
you get over it you know you get over it
at the end of the day it's what i love
prioritize what you want to do right
exactly yeah exactly why else am i here
you know
and not make me think that exactly i
mean if that was the case then i'd quit
and yeah um i mean if if you want me to
to stay here i'm going to do what i want
to do yeah that's all i can say